hello what you are a very warm welcome
from our side my name is Jen's flow
stove I'm the spokesperson of transition
team a few of you already know my face
but it would be good if you would tell
your name and your media metric or a
question later as you know the last few
weeks we had a lot of internal work to
do forming the structure and composition
of the new college therefore I ask for
your understanding in advance at this
stage we are not yet in a position to go
deep into details and specific policy
areas but we are here and we're ready to
answer what can be answered today right
after this press conference you can find
some more detailed information on the
structure on the website of the
Commission also in the mission letters
on the portfolios and of course the
codecs from the SPP will always be
available available for you so Madam
President Elect thank you very much I
would like to start off by thanking
president Juncker for his welcome and
support over the last few weeks he has
very kindly made available to me his
team's amazing people and he's also made
his press room available to me today now
I've known no jean-claude jankis ever
since I've been involved in politics
I've learnt a great deal from him I owe
him a great deal as well so it will be a
great honour for me to follow in his
footsteps
today I'm presenting my team for Europe
it draws on all these strengths and
talents men and women experienced and
young east and west south and north a
team that is well balanced a team that
brings together diversity of experience
and competence I want a commission that
is led with determination that is
clearly focused on the issues at hand
and that provides answers the
vice-president's are responsible for the
priorities in my political guidelines
the European Green Deal a Europe fit for
the digital age an economy that works
for people a stronger Europe in the
world protecting our European Way of
life and a new push for European
democracy these vice presidents will
steer our work in the overarching issues
the commissioners are the center of my
team they will manage the expertise
provided by specialized directorates in
general I want this commission to be a
flexible a modern an agile Commission I
want to provide a college that is
committed that understands Europe that
listens to what Europeans want this is
why I expect for example all members of
college to visit every member state in
the first half of our mandate we should
not only get to know the capitals but
also visit the regions in which the
people of Europe live and work and this
will be a commission that walks the talk
just as Europe must become fit for the
digital age so must the Commission
therefore college meetings will be
paperless and they will be digital and
yes our goal is to make life easier for
people and business in other words also
to reduce the administrative burden
therefore when we create new laws and
regulations we will apply the principle
of wunen
one out and we will develop an
instrument to measure this we want to
cut red tape
I want this college to be gender
balanced but I also want this college to
be balanced geographically and as you
can see the vice-president's come from
east and west from north and south of
the european union we have a structure
that focuses on tasks not on hierarchies
depending on the topics the members of
the college will work in different
clusters we need to be able to deliver
on the issues that matter the most
rapidly and with determination that is
why I have given my executive vice
presidents a double function they will
be both vice president and commissioner
they will coordinate our work on the
topics that cut across our society and
the economy these are the overarching
topics and they will have their own
policy to manage within this broader
topic I want to show this how this works
in practice
Hansa moments will be the executive vice
president for the European Green Deal
I want the European Green Deal to become
Europe's hallmark at the heart of it is
our commitment to becoming the world's
first climate neutral continent it is
also long-term economic imperative
because those who act first and fast
will be the ones who grasp the
opportunities from the ecological
transition I want you to be the front
runner
I want Europe to be the exporter
of technologies knowledge best practice
consumer months will lead the work on
the European Green Deal
he will also manage climate action
policy supported by a DG clima and he
will work together with the
commissioners for agriculture health
transport energy cohesion and reforms
and Environment and Oceans executive
vice president margarita vest area will
lead our work on the Europe fit for the
digital age
digitalization has a huge impact on the
way we live we work we communicate in
some fields Europe has to catch up for
example in the field
business-to-consumer but another fields
we're excellent Europe is the
front-runner for example in
business-to-business when we talk about
digital twins of products and procedures
we have to make more out of the field of
artificial intelligence we have to make
our single market a digital single
market we have to use way more the big
data that is out there but we don't make
enough out of it what innovation and
startups are concerned it's not only
need to know but it's also need to share
big data we have to improve on
cybersecurity we have to work hard on
our technological sovereignity just to
name a few issues issues in these broad
topics margarita vestroia will
coordinate the whole agenda and be the
Commissioner for competition she will
work together with a commissioner for
internal market innovation and youth
transferred
energy jobs health and justice executive
vice president Valdez Dombrowski's will
lead our work on an economy that works
for people we have a unique social
market economy it is the source of our
prosperity and social fairness this is
all the more important when we face now
twin transitions climate digital I was
just talking about virus Dombrowski's
will lead our work to bring together the
social and the market in our economy and
he will be the Commissioner for
financial services he will work together
with commissioners for economy jobs
internal market cohesion and reforms
trade innovation and youth you will have
time to get to know all the names of the
commissioners but let me tell you a bit
more about a few of my team Virginia's
Singh cabbages he is 28 years old and he
shows that Europe is ready to hand
responsibility over to the younger
generation he will be responsible for
our environment and oceans Yuta or pline
she was not only finance minister our
long-standing member of the Finnish
Parliament's Foreign Affairs Committee
but she was also a special envoy working
in Ethiopia she will take over
responsibility for international
partnerships which is crucial for our
neighborhood it's crucial that we invest
heavily in our neighbourhood we have
this international partnership to create
jobs in these areas
sylvie gula she's a dedicated and
convinced European she will lead our
work on industrial policy and she will
promote the digital single market she
will also be responsible for the newly
created director-general defense
industry and space
I think our investment in common
procurement in Europe as Europeans will
have an enormous Bulova effect in the
private business industry upholding the
rule of law
will remain a top priority for Europe
and this is why I have entrusted to
experienced members of my team with this
responsibility DT Reinders as
commissioner for justice and where are
yer over as vice president for values
and transparency I cannot go in detail
through every commissioners portfolio
although each of them has their own
story each has their own skills and
they're all part of our team but there
is one fundamental concern that connects
this team we want to bring new impetus
to Europe's democracy this is our joint
responsibility and democracy is more
than voting in elections every five
years it is about having your voice
heard it's about having being able to
participate in the way our society is
built we have to address some of the
deeper issues in our society that have
have led to a loss of faith in democracy
I'm thinking of people who feel left
behind by progress and transitions I'm
thinking of people who feel cut off for
isolated
due to a lack for example in their
regions of infrastructure like public
transportations or hospitals for schools
or even post offices in their villages
people who see their children leave
their home cities in search of
opportunities elsewhere and if you look
closely the root issues for this anger
for this discontent for this frustration
sometimes is one of more demographic
change rather than democracy and we
should not accept this as given many
regions and rural areas have shown us
that you can turn this around and this
is why I have put to Braska Schwitzer as
vice-president for democracy and
demography she knows how towns cities
regions community stick
she was mayor of Dubrovnik and she has
been a member of a national and the
European Parliament she comes from our
youngest member state Croatia she will
lead from the Commission side the work
on the conference on the future of
Europe this is the team that will serve
Europe with dedication in the Commission
and you'll get in a moment printouts in
a moment you'll get printouts
this is the team that will have to gain
Parliament's confidence this is the team
that will shape the European Way build
our partnership with the United States
of America although we have issues but
they are our closest allies define our
relation with a more self assertive
China
be a reliable neighbor for example to
Africa stand up for our values and
world-class standards this commission
will be a geopolitical commission
I want the European Union and that's the
Commission to be the guardian of
multilateralism because we know that we
are stronger by doing together what we
cannot do alone and I would like to ask
the staff to distribute the hard copies
for those who can read the details on
the screen I'll wait for a moment
are we all set
are we all set with the hard copies now
I wanted to go through the different
portfolios
there's Vice President Joseph Ferrell
current Spanish foreign minister he will
be a high representative vice-president
designate in charge of a stronger Europe
in the world there is vice president
Margaret esquinas
from Greece you know him as a former
member of the European Parliament you
know him as a long-serving official in
the European Commission he calls himself
a true believer in Europe he will be the
vice president for protecting our
European way of life
there's vice-president Mirage chef
kovitch from Slovakia he will be
responsible for international relations
and foresight he will strengthen our
culture on evidence-based policymaking
this Commissioner paolo gentiloni from
italy you'll know him as form Italian
Prime Minister and Minister of Foreign
Affairs he will be sharing his vast
experience in the economy portfolio
there is Commissioner Johannes Hahn from
Austria as a long-serving member of the
college she knows about the importance
of nurturing a modern administration he
will be in charge of budget and
administration and he will report
directly to me this commissioner Maria
Gabrielle from Bulgaria she is a current
european commissioner she worked with
dedication on the digital portfolio and
she's now moving on
to create new perspectives to the young
generation with the portfolio innovation
and youth there Stella Keely kiriakidis
from Cyprus sorry Stella she is a
medical psychologist with many many
years of experience in the field of
Social Affairs health and cancer
prevention she will lead the health
portfolio this Kadri Simpson from
Estonia she's a long-serving member of
the Estonian Parliament and Minister for
Economic Affairs and infrastructure she
will be in charge of the energy
portfolio des last load tour Shani he is
the former Minister of Justice of
Hungary he will lead the neighbourhood
and enlargement portfolio Phil Hogan
Hogan from Ireland the incumbent
Commissioner for agriculture he is known
as a heart and a fair negotiator he will
bring his experience to the new
Commission in the trade portfolio
Nikolas MIT from Luxembourg is bringing
his experience from the European
Parliament and his service as a National
Minister for employment and labor and he
will now be responsible for the jobs
portfolio Helena Dahle from Malta has
dedicated her political life to equality
she has been serving as minister for
social dialogue Consumer Affairs and
civil liberties and for European affairs
and equality she will lead the Equality
portfolio Janusz avoid tchaikovsky
Poland was a long serving member of the
European Parliament in the Agriculture
Committee and is currently a member of
the European Court of Auditors he will
be in charge of the portfolio
Agricola after portfolio agriculture
ELISA Ferreira from Portugal is
currently vice governor of the banco de
port to gallop she has been a member of
the European Parliament for many many
years and she was the Portuguese
Minister for planning and Minister for
environment she will lead the cohesion
and reforms portfolio ravana bloomed
from romania is a member of the european
parliament and is a former National
Minister of Environment and climate
change labour and European funds she
will be in charge of the transport
portfolio
Yanis lenarcik from slovenia is a
slovenian diplomat he was Secretary of
State for European affairs and work
closely for several years with the
United Nations and the Organization for
Security and Cooperation in Europe he
will be in charge of the crisis
management portfolio Oliva johansson
from Sweden she has been a minister
national Minister for employment but
also former minister for schools and for
health and elderly care and she has been
a member of the Swedish parliament
she is also highly respected as expert
in the field of employment integration
health and welfare
she's hands-on if you want something to
be done ask her she will lead the Home
Affairs portfolio this is the team as
diverse as Europe is as strong as Europe
is there was a dedicated men and women
and I'm looking forward working with
this team for Europe thank you so much
was the first question Urich
you could feel it from the newspaper as
well
VCC madam Ella president
easy well I'm here present what's the
political message you're sending out to
various countries by choosing madam yova
you have poster
Minister of her party is the subject of
an Olaf investigation so worthy sir
firms are all sorts of illegal questions
so I'm not there doubting the honesty of
a Madame Europa herself but what's the
political message you're sending out by
making back to appointment terms and
perhaps you could just expand a bit on
what the European Way of life portfolio
WA is er all Valtor and what exactly is
margarita sestinas they're going to be
responsible for in he said
director-general explicitly saying that
there is no doubt at all about the
competence and the independence of Vera
arava and I think it is important that
with the topic of rule of law we show it
matters to all of us in Europe therefore
we have DT renders as a foreign minister
who was one of the first who developed
the initiative to have a screening and
monitoring throughout whole of Europe
about any member state what the topic of
rule of law is concerned and of course
it is a topic that is not showing in any
kind of geographical direction of the
European Union but we have a
representative from the western part we
have a representative from the Central
and Eastern European part both of them
will work closely together in a very
independent way and I want to make sure
whoever is here as a candidate is first
and foremost a European of the European
Commission
Margarita's kinas will as the political
guideline shows in my guidelines I've
laid out to the Parliament he will be
responsible for the topic migration but
also for the topic skilled labor skilled
migration and he'll be responsible for
the topic of protect
it is the whole chain that he will work
on cross cutting through the different
portfolios commissioners do have when we
talk about successful managing migration
and having a sustainable concept for
migration it starts in the countries of
origin where we do have to invest
heavily so that there is a perspective
for jobs and a future for people incomes
at that point you two or P lion with
international partnerships we're talking
about fighting hard against trafficking
and smuggling
this is organized crime and we have to
fight it hard we have to deal with
effective humane but functioning
external borders in order to have free
movement in the Schengen area and we
have to be clear about what is Asylum
who is eligible for asylum and what are
we doing with those who coming the
migrants who coming irregularly who are
not eligible for asylum and we will have
to develop this whole chain of action on
the topic of migration of course we know
that those who are irregular migrants
will have to go back to their countries
of origin but it has to be a noble task
of the European Union to be willing to
take on refugees who are you who need
protection to the European Union but in
a way that is orderly and it is regular
and this whole topic is also combined
with a question of skilled labor because
you know that being a continent that
needs skilled labor the lord of tasks to
tackle at home within the european union
but we also have to organise a correct
way to have skilled migration
to Europe and this whole package will be
in the portfolio of vice-president
margaritas Skinner's just be I work we
work our way through we've got a plenty
of time this iconic with a white jacket
over here too much research for for the
in our Christian on topic are
you
Hunter's Cabral catalyst in a fresh mag
and true except I'm a Catholic news
agency I have a few questions you talked
about a Commissioner for international
partner shaft and there was the idea of
having an Africa Commissioner as well so
why did you ultimately decide against
having such a post yes I'd be happy to
answer that question there was a
proposal to have an Africa Commissioner
and I discussed this issue with
representatives from the African Union
and interestingly enough this was
considered to be discriminatory
potentially so the argument was put
forward right away
hang on a minute what about a
Commissioner for Latin America or one
for Asia or one for the Middle East or
the Near East so I respect that argument
and that's why you parochial einen is
the one who has this broad portfolio
where economical cooperation in our in
neighboring countries that's why she's
going to manage that broad portfolio
yeah blue just easily we've got plenty
of times people go through yeah - I
needed a petite Alisha targets are gonna
be near a forum island president is
capitulate there's been criticism Madam
President but we have a highly indebted
country and they are providing the
economics commissioner so what do you
say to those critics what's your comment
on that yes that's an important subject
and I discussed this in great detail
with paolo gentiloni and prime minister
20 but paolo gentiloni
here
a very experienced two former
prime-minister Surrey knows exactly what
the difficult issues are which we have
to deal with at the moment first and
foremost we are Europeans in the
European Commission and for us it's
decisive to have a clever combination a
well balanced distribution net of views
and points of focus
well this Dombrowski's is the executive
vice president and he's going to work
very closely with paolo gentiloni we
know that did the economy commissioner
but we also know that in italy the
finance minister
roberto katya comes from the european
parliament with a huge amount of
experience on that the stability and
growth pact for example and he knows
exactly what our commonly agreed rules
are in europe rules which we arrived at
because this strengthens us these rules
make us stronger it moves Europe forward
and we know that if we respect those
rules so this will benefit all of us and
Roberto Vittori knows exactly what's
happening at the European level what's
been agreed there and what the
expectations are there and this
combination I believe will allow us to
strike a very good balance to deal with
these difficult issues and make progress
in these areas within the framework of
which we have agreed commonly within
Europe oh please one question yeah it's
a corner please point the Irish
Commissioner to the trade portfolio a
message to the United Kingdom of what to
expect were they to be trying to
negotiate a free trade agreement after a
No Deal brexit I know Phil Hogan as an
excellent very fair a negotiator and he
has handled the agriculture portfolio
in a brilliant way and this is what I
expect of him as a trade commissioner he
will be a very fair but determined
negotiator and what our friends from the
United Kingdom's are concerned I think
it is very important to have together a
very good free-trade agreement so that
because I think it will be determining
the good relations we want to have in
the future we are still in a difficult
process but I keep saying that the
brexit we never wanted but we respect
decisions that are taken by our British
friends by the United Kingdom the brexit
should it happen is not the end of
something but it's the beginning of our
future relationship and I want these
relationship as it has been in the past
in the future to be a good relationship
and therefore I think the Trade
Commissioner Sal Hogan who will have to
deal with all the different trade
agreements we are negotiating is an
excellent choice I beg your pardon them
because I don't know all your names I
try to find for myself a kind of
geographical balance here and we
continue here up here yep you please we
take truth questions here and then we go
around in circles and we've got plenty
of time any question is just to confirm
given that Dombrowski's would be
executive vice president it would be in
charge of the DG I assume so he will be
the last word when deciding for example
in the case of the Italian dose here and
second question we were told by a
president scientist that boreg will be
in charge of Africa and also
humanitarian aid among other issues so I
wanted to confirm whether that's truth
we were told that during the last summit
in July so I wanted to confirm what that
border will be in charge of Africa
irregular migration and also
humanitarian aid
yeah first of all what HR VP Burrell is
concerned of course he will be the vice
president dealing with the commissioner
for international partnerships dealing
with the Commissioner for enlargement
and neighbourhood dealing with the
commissioner for human rights management
which was humanity and is humanitarian
aid - and of course he has a huge task
to tackle what our neighborhood is
concerned as it is with each high
representative so we'll have an
important role to play in our
neighbourhood in Africa for example your
first point was on Dombrowski's and
paolo gentiloni any final decision is
being taken by the college so this is
these are decisions we take together and
we explain together and we defend and
argue together about why they have been
taken the way they are taken yes please
almost but okay give me a news
television and my question would be
Madam President could you please explain
on enlighten the background of picking
where a euro vice vice president who is
responsible for a rule of law as well
can it be considered as a consider G
message to the center Eastern European
countries I have answered exact the same
question a few minutes ago There is
obviously consensus also in this room
that where our yurov are very
independent did an excellent job as
commissioner for justice in the outgoing
commission and we have the same
combination as it was on the rule of law
the outgoing Commission we had a vice
president responsible and the
Commissioner for justice in the incoming
Commission we will have a vice president
and the Commissioner for justice Didier
Reynders together with Vera yoruba and
as there is no doubt at all about the
independence of both I do not see any
problem on the contrary I think it is
important to bring that topic forward in
a way that will be that the Commissioner
and the vice president will be able to
explain it to the people of Europe the
colleague from AFP
I'm a from a Johnson's place madam in
your team
yes I'm over here there are a number of
commissioners who are questionable and a
couple of them subject to an Olaf
inquiry investigation why did you not
just turn them down because otherwise
your commission might already have this
tarnished image including people who are
suspected of having committed fraud even
though they are presumed innocent
we had mrs. christow at the time of the
santa Cabernet and miss we had a problem
mr. Darley and that was a problem for
the Commissioner after don't you think
you might be in a similar position
yourself one day don't you think it's up
to you to say no to the Member States in
order to be more independent
I must apologize what do you know that's
quite all right as you said Olaf is an
independent body and that's how it
should be one is always presumed to be
innocent as you quite rightly pointed
out and finally let me say that the list
of Commissioners proposed was accepted
by the council which is always necessary
I think we have an excellent list of men
and women I am NOT going to comment on
Olaf's investigations because they are
entirely independent they will conclude
their work and we will listen to what
they have to say it was a question yeah
please up there yep you with red
you
and polish television I would like to
ask madam a president about Polish
candidate
Janusz royalty have scanned the
agriculture what he will be responsible
exactly on what he will be he said
duties in your commission thank you very
much well it is the whole and huge
portfolio of Agriculture and Rural
Development and I would not be able now
in this press conference to elaborate on
this huge topic it is exactly the same
portfolio as we have it right now in the
outgoing Commission it's an important
one and the details will be discussed
with the commissioners actually they
have their mission letters right now
we're very much detailed whether there's
very much detailed out what their duties
tasks and the expectations are pleased
waiting for a long time albans Justice
Minister is here on does mr. Tross
Connie have enough credible experience
to promote and insist on rule of law in
Western Balkans as this is going to be
his ultimate goal as future enlargement
Commissioner and also you have seen that
you have upgraded the position previous
position was enlargement negotiations
now it's only enlargement a
neighbourhood is this a positive signal
that something concerning enlargement
indeed significantly will happen during
your mandate the portfolio is exactly
the same what you will have noticed that
as the names of the portfolio's got
longer and longer over time we reduced
it for example the portfolio jobs or the
portfolio internal market internal
market has entrepreneurship industry
policy internal market defense industry
space so we reduced it to internal
market
and same goes for neighborhood and
enlargement the portfolio substance is
absolutely the same just the chronic in
front of you please yeah Robert Watson
friends Europe I just wanted to ask the
the executive vice presidential
positions have very long titles which
might not necessarily tell the public
immediately what the job of the person
involved is so do you think this is the
way to make people feel closer to the
Commission second one is there's no
individual Commissioner for climate and
given you've given the environment
portfolio to a younger commissioner do
you not think given the level of support
amongst the youth of Europe for climate
action it might have been a a nice
gesture to name a younger Commissioner
in a climate role public of Europe and
the use of Europe will only be convinced
if we deliver and therefore we have
clear goals and we have a clear plan
which is the European Green Deal what
the titles are concerned I think they
are very much more understandable then
sometime type was used to be to the
public they are exactly the guidelines
from taken from my political guidelines
I laid out to the Parliament a few weeks
ago the genius is an excellent young
dedicated determined politician who has
already aname in that field in that area
and I'm absolutely convinced that he
will be insisting us to see us
undelivered on that subject of the
European Green Deal and he will have a
strong vice-president that is France
timmermans so together and I'm convinced
that we will have to show a lot of
result but as I said we will only
convince youth when we
deliver deliver deliver no just try to
yeah please no no no at your left side
just yeah the woman press a blue with a
blue jacket please reporter can I ask
you president you met with President
Juncker yesterday for a working lunch
and you in the past he's argued that
there should be maybe a smaller college
fewer commissioners would you support
that given your experience over recent
weeks and if I could ask another
question if I may and you've said in
your first initial presentation to the
Parliament that you would be open to the
idea of an extension for the UK as we
know the UK is legally obliged to seek
that extension shoot a deal not be
arrived at at the next council obviously
you come in to post on the 1st of
November is there something that you
discussed with President Juncker and
what is he minded to do should that
request be received I cannot talk for
President Juncker here but we are in a
regular basis we are meeting and having
lunch together so that we do have a
smooth transition it is right I'm gonna
be an office on the 1st of November but
the next steps are completely in the
hands and the decision of the United
Kingdom so I will not comment on their
decisions and the next steps they might
take so we'll see how things will
proceed president Juncker we I have been
discussing the college and I learn a lot
from these meetings because he tells me
a lot about what he has done and what
was a goddess
and what was a mistake perhaps I should
avoid so it's wonderful to learn a lot
from him what the size of the college is
concerned each member state
is sending a candidate so this reflects
Europe as it is the European Union at
the moment being so it's wonderful to
have this diversity and the size is
completely reflecting the size of the
European Union at the moment be take a
question up there please could you give
someone a mic here to engage Serbia if I
can echo a question asked by my
colleague about reasons that led you to
propose Commissioner from Hungary to
take the enlargement portfolio so what
were the what was the reasoning behind
especially knowing that there are many
critics pointing out that the issues of
rule of law in Hungary while that same
issue is the key aspect of the
enlargement process for the Balkan
countries Thank You general that Hungary
is a country that has a clear objective
as I do have that we the Western Balkans
are very important for us and I want
them as close as possible to the
European Union I want very good relation
intensive work and cooperation with them
this will be one of my main focus in
this presidency so this is a very
important topic and I think that Hungary
is a country that will work exactly in
that sense one more question here in
front on this side here please
good please someone give
these colleagues for someone who met at
Mike please do you have a mic yep yes
Angela orpington post Italy there is a
discussion on the Italian side of the
und growth and stability pact what would
be the approach but new Commission
towards this issue thank you we have a
growth and stability pact that has been
developed out of the experience of the
economic crisis and in a broad consensus
finally that we want strong European
Union a strong economy a strong Europe
and therefore the rules are clear the
limits are clear the flexibility is
clear so within these rules we will
tackle the different options and issues
we have to discuss the combination of
paolo gentiloni Tabasco beurre cherry by
these Dombrowski's we've just been
talking about a few minutes ago so we'll
see what the next steps are we expect
the budget drafts and then we'll see the
next steps please the next question here
the gentleman in the second row is he
good morning
I'm from ABC a Spanish newspaper I would
like to put a question now when you
appoint a commissioner for enlargement
of course that means that you are
envisaging including other member states
in the Union which countries do you
think will be moving forward in the next
mandate and what do you think about the
candidacy of Turkey yes thank you well
of course it does depend on the country
itself how they move towards Europe
we're talking about values
and rules we have in Europe our rules
haven't changed these are our founding
values and if countries want to join us
they have to show us and they have to
work towards having the same rules and
conditions and they have to show us that
they are able to be members of the
European Union now I can't come up with
any ranking for you now because it
depends very much on the countries in
the Western Balkans
when it comes to Turkey I haven't seen
this kind of progress over the last few
years on the contrary in fact and that
is why what I said is correct
it's up to others to show that they
wanted to move closer to European values
European rules rule of law freedoms
freedom these are our fundamental values
and this is something I have not
witnessed over the past few years
it Aziza from the Portuguese daily
público is just wondering if you could
give us a brief overview of Commissioner
Elizabeth Ida's new portfolio is it an
enhanced regional policy portfolio
perhaps with some plan you mixed with it
so that you can mitigate the proposed
cuts to structural funds thank you
the portfolio of cohesion funds with
structural reforms plus the new just
transition fund the new just transition
fund is part of the European Green Deal
we are aware that we have to progress
rapidly in developed technologies green
financing but we also aware that this
will mean a lot of change in some
regions for example heavily codependent
regions will have to change their their
business sector therefore an enormous
transition will be there also for people
and to invest directly in that field
therefore we will have the just
transition fund so it's specifically for
the European Green Deal the transition
we have to go through but therefore it's
good in combination with one
commissioner who's also responsible for
the structural reforms
the cohesion funds please here Sam
Fleming from the Financial Times
I wanted to ask about Commission
vestiges a new portfolio in particular
the logic behind giving her the
competition portfolio that continued
portfolio obviously this will be a
controversial decision particularly in
the Trump administration which has
attacked her in the past are you
stressed your desire to work closely
with America have you what thoughts have
you had about that particular aspect of
the vice president the executive vice
president's new portfolio thank you
only aspect that matters assigning
portfolios is quality and excellence and
margarita West here has done an
outstanding job as a commissioner for
competition so and competition and the
issues she's tackling they're closely
linked to the digital sector too so
having her as an executive vice
president for the digital in Europe is
absolutely a perfect combination she
will have this topic as a cross-cutting
topic she'll have to work on the digital
single market she will work on the fact
that we want to use in a better way big
data that is out there that we collect
every day non-personalized data that we
should use way better in the need for
example to share with others for
innovation for startups for new ideas
she will work on the whole topic of
cybersecurity which is the more we
digitalized the more we will neural so
there's a huge field in front of her and
as she's shown excellence in the
Commission portfolio she will keep that
the executive vice president's have with
the DG's kind of muscles to deal with
their vast portfolios or subject they
have to deal with taken from
yep join the famiiy was attended Madam
President when you were building up the
Commission did you think that you had
done too few meaningful portfolios and
too many commissioners and if the UK
stays in and would they have to wear
send out a commissioner to Brussels well
we have so many themes to deal with in
Europe we want to be a strong
geopolitical commission and all the
issues which have come up here today it
just shows how dense these portfolios
are and how big they are how big the
subjects are so it was if anything more
difficult to focus things to to
concentrate things and to find enough
commissioners to cover all these
subjects and I think that that just
bears witness er to him how bigger the
the European Union that is we have fun
huge challenges to take up we are an
international player we have to be
visible on the big questions in
discussions with the US we've had
discussions like this and what about
China what's our role in the Middle East
another big issue how can we bring about
enough investment so that we can
invest in our neighboring there
countries are also way in Africa in
order to improve the prospects there so
just in a nutshell you can see that
number the European Green Deal is a huge
subject area and I think that this will
mark our work in the coming years and
decades and the same goes for red the
digital age and then on your question on
the UK a potential UK Commissioner well
we'll have to see what happens
you
so on the first of November we'll see
what happens and if the UK were to ask
for an extension and if that were
granted then according to the rules of
the treaty then yes Commissioner would
have to be appointed and then that
person would receive a portfolio Center
as there are plenty of questions in the
centre so please just wait with your
phone a bit I have two questions there's
one thing I didn't quite understand
we have energy and climate I didn't
really understand that the difference
between the two the division between the
two so what about international
conferences who's going to be
representing the EU there and second
question this is really a follow-up
question on enlargement up until now the
EU has to be willing to accept new
members is this something that's now
been forgotten Aurum are you still open
to him to potential them accession
candidates on climate well we have
friends Timmerman's are responsible for
that
with the DG clima and the European Green
Deal well a kateri Simpson is
responsible for air energy and she's
part of that she's part of the cluster
which I was outlining before together
with France timmermans as a
vice-president 'im who's heading up a DG
climber so close cooperation there on
the subject of enlargement we had a
question a minute ago on that the the
order of membership of accessions
potentially I think the most important
thing is that to make it clear that the
EU is not the one that has to change
those countries which would like to join
they have to show and we want to a
support as I said development they have
to show that they are respecting that
the principles fundamental values and
also were the economic and financial
conditions for example they have to show
that they respect all of that to meet
the conditions for joining the EU
another a clear steps so at the opening
up of chapters and then the closing of
the different of chapters and joint
decisions have to be taken in each case
I think the great thing about the
European Union one of the great things
is that so many countries over the past
60 70 years they've done everything in
their power to be in a position to join
the EU and many commissioners of vice
presidents they come from countries
which have shown which have demonstrated
how much is meant to them to be able to
join the European Union and how much
we've gained together the accession
countries are the country sir which were
already members and also whether the
European way of thinking
overall that's a really beautiful thing
about of the European Union it's really
unique to us
my question concerns energy topic
because one of the main issues of this
commission is climate tackling climate
change and one of the key portfolios is
energy could you describe a bit your
expectations torch portfolio of code
regimes and a second question you
mentioned that bureaucracy in a European
Commission will be paper free how could
you imagine it will happen from the
first day of your office
a of this college the college meetings
will be paperless so beginning in
November the college meetings will be
paperless and only digital this is the
start and I've known this administration
as being very digital already so what I
was talking about the college meetings
matter of course we can get way better
in the overall performance as not only
the European Commission's administration
but the whole of Europe what the energy
portfolio is concerned it's a huge
portfolio and I can only roughly go
through a few buzzwords otherwise this
will take way too much time at the
moment being of course energy has to be
reliable we need diversity well has to
be diversified the supply of energy it
has to be affordable and it has to be
resource or climate friendly and
renewable and this is not a ranking I
just put in place so there you have
already the outline of where you have to
move forward within a portfolio it's a
very important portfolio there's an
enormous amount to do and I'm sure Kerry
Simpson will do a perfect job
the second question from this side and
we moved to the center competition it's
now a part of the digital portfolio does
that mean that competition should be
further politicized in its decisions to
create European digital champions is
that the idea and also where will be the
oversight of all the murders that are
not digital will that also be part of
mrs. västerås portfolio or will that be
part of industrial strategy industrial
policy something else maybe also can you
tell us whether there will be
thank you soon so competition as
portfolio stays as it is so and there
are a lot of digital topics in it but
this does not mean that every topic is
digital every potential merger or every
task in it is concerning digitalization
but it has to low dual out with
digitalization so the portfolio stays as
it is and I cannot follow your
assumption that the digitalization of
the European Union is politicizing a
topic it's a must it's of utmost
importance for a European Union if we
want to be successful what the society
is concerned but also what our economy
is concerned we have to urgently catch
up in digitalization I said there are
some fields where we're good at but this
is certainly not the vast majority so
it's an enormous important topic that
craft cuts cross across all different
layers of society and the business
sector and all our work here in the
European Union and in the college
therefore a cluster is huge too and
there's an enormous amount of work to do
now recording in the front row who was
waiting for such a long time
Jeremy Fleming from PAH just on the same
topic on competition and this digital
cluster are you anticipating that there
will be concerns about conflicts of
interests crossing across that cluster
and will there be safeguards to ensure
that competition is somehow preserved in
its ring-fence State yes as I said the
the DG stays as it is
the director-general stays as it is so
with the same strength and assertiveness
and important it had so the Commissioner
Margaret of Estella
this term has done an outstanding job
but I'm sure she will even do better by
being also a vice president for the
digitalization of the European Union -
must be placed by the unloved as my
second attempt you responded on that the
Olaf cases have switched to English
preservation to a question which is
everybody here keen to know first of all
we would like to know about your
structure will in the future under your
mandate every Commissioner will have its
own spokesperson under the UK Commission
their mitigated to sweep portfolios for
one people this is one crucial question
and second would be who will be your
chief spokes woman in the future from
1st of November which we would like to
know as well thank you
I accept totally these these are very
important questions for the room here I
think till the end of the week we gonna
be set with the question who's gonna be
a spokesperson so you'll get the answer
in an orderly manner that's not at the
moment be just some question in the
middle you get the mic to the lady over
there
thank you this is the portfolio
innovation and youth okay we say in the
middle okay leaning on the line madam
from the Lions we have the agriculture
commissioner from the country receiving
the most subsidies but - we need to make
major savings in the budget so how does
that work and if you appoint an energy
minister from via Baltic how does that
fit in with the construction of North
stream not stream deceived us via well I
think the really important thing is and
this is a fundamental message to all
Commissioners or vice presidents the
main point is that you are Europeans now
first and foremost so you have to act in
the European interest that goes for
energy and the position of the
Commission is very clear on this and
I've talked about this so with all the
candidate commissioners for the
different portfolios you are no longer
representatives or messengers from your
countries maybe you were when you were
ministers and so on but the situation
has changed so here first and foremost
you are Europeans and represent European
positions and the position sir coming
from the the Commission will there be
arrived at in the College of
Commissioners so that applies to the
agriculture sector as well in principle
so on
the different financial ceilings and so
on all that that has to be negotiated
for agriculture and I expect from
everyone who deals with beer budget that
we will balance the different European
interests obviously commissioners will
be fighting for their portfolios but
overall this has to be in the European
interest
the mic can be move up there to you
thank you just hear Matina Stavis for
the New York Times two questions you've
spoken a lot about European values today
in particular in the context of the
accession of aspiring members country's
neighbors including Turkey you made it
clear that you don't believe turkey
shares Europe's values and so I want to
ask you are you going to continue with
the policy of handing billions of euros
to countries that don't share Europe's
values to keep migrants away from the
European Union
the previous Commission granted a six
billion euro package to Turkey will you
renew this and what are the pitfalls of
doing this in giving you know countries
this kind of money for this type of
policy and secondly could you elaborate
on the idea behind the dg4 defense
what will the competences be and how
does that fit into Europe's you know
European Member States membership of
NATO etc thank you yes perhaps I started
with a lot of second question first NATO
will always be collective defence
without any question a NATO is the
strongest military alliance in the world
the European Union will never be a
military alliance but the European Union
has been told many many times the member
states of the European Union have are
being taught within NATO that
interoperability that is common
procurement for their Armed Forces is of
utmost importance that has been the
message over decades I'd say so now the
European Union is moving forward because
it is sensible and it is the right thing
to do to have procurement in a common
way so the European Union is moving
forward it is the new DG defense
industry and space what is the thought
behind it we do have the European
defence firm
and it is a right idea to enable the
European member states to do the
research the development and the
procurement for the future systems we
will have together knowing that this
will improve anonymously
interoperability which is actually of
benefit for NATO we have one single set
of courses so it's of benefit from it
but it's also of benefit for the
industrial bases in the European Union
because we know that publicly driven
research and development of procurement
has an enormous spill over effect in the
private civil industrial sector so there
are research topics that would never be
have been developed if it weren't for
the common procurement I give you
examples that you all know the American
DARPA was the one that nurtured the
development of the internet for the
American armed forces forces same goes
for GPS we wouldn't have GPS today if it
weren't for the Armed Forces research
and development today nobody would think
about it so therefore it is of utmost
importance for the economic and
industrial basis of the European Union
and the basic research on these huge
topics to have a common approach and the
new director-general for defense is
working on that
your other question thanks God I have a
pen so I keep it in mind the turkey EU
agreement was an important and complex
money it said first of all actually that
we put a NATO vessel
a NATO mission NATO activity in the
agency to watch over the smuggling and
trafficking the organized crime at the
Turkish border that was bringing over in
these horrible rubber boats
approximately five thousand migrants per
day in 2016-17 those were the years it
was hugely organized crime this stopped
now the numbers have gone down
drastically then the second point is for
every irregular migrant it comes to the
European side and that we have to bring
back we will take another migrant from
at that time Syria for example to the
European Union and on top the European
Union is willing to invest six billion
in the refugee camps for example for
schooling of these children in the
refugee camps so now there is a debate
has the whole sum being paid there are
different numbers out there
I think numbers have to be clarified
because we're all accountable to that
but this was the bay and is the basic
idea of it yeah it started a second row
and then we move up to you guys so I'm
from a Swiss television what about
relations between Switzerland and the EU
is this going to be something you will
be responsible for as mr. Juncker was or
will it be given to someone such as mr.
Tortoni aesthetically now and
if you can answer nail whatever language
you you you like French German that
since I'm from Switzerland does his
Suisse well the Swiss file is very
important
I haven't yet decided where it is to be
dealt with but it's an important one
negotiations which have been carried out
were very good indeed I would like to
work with this agreement which was a
negotiated in Switzerland and I'll
switch to German now because it's a
easier no decision has been taken yet
but this issue is of particular
importance and I think that the
negotiations so far between the current
Commission and Switzerland that has have
gone very well so what I intend to build
on that besides just three rows yep yes
this is Jo Kerwin from Bloomberg tax and
your campaign to win approval in the
European Parliament you made a number of
commitments on the taxation front and
these concerned corporate taxation
digital taxation and also on the carbon
border tax you haven't mentioned any of
that where how that would be broken down
into the portfolio so could you explain
will it be different where they fall
under different portfolios or will it be
in the case of say Commissioner
Moscovici taxation is under his
portfolio strictly thank you he's
excused but the the outlining detailed
outlining of all the topics of the
European Green Deal and you are talking
about something which might occur but is
not at all in the discussion at the
moment being will be met with the matter
of the working program that we will Dow
will lay down till the end of the year
so
at that point we will show exactly how
the different steps for the European
Green Deal will be and then the
decisions will be taken at that time how
to organize the European Green Deal the
supervision and that has the executive
vice president France gentleman
hospitalized month and the gentleman in
front of you
Thank You Paula pie from u-turn release
Croatia I have a question but I'm sure
it's a vice-president for democracy and
demography what is the idea of linking
those two we understand that demographic
challenges particularly in Croatia but
some people are saying that some member
states have problems with democracy
democratic values as well so will she be
dealing also with the democracy in the
EU member states or it's something else
behind this idea and which DG will be
under her responsibility if any thanks
the the respectable clusters are laid
out in the mission letters we've shown a
few as an example here on the screen so
the topic she will be responsible for
the huge topic from the Commission side
what the conference on the future of
Europe is concerned this is an enormous
process it's a vital process for our
democracy and she will be the one from
the Commission side we will do that in
close cooperation with the Parliament
and the council so it's not only a
Commission's project but it's of utmost
importance to roll out this program over
the next two and a half year and then to
be able to collect the knowledge that
we've won out of it in my introductory
remarks I stressed that I think some of
the points of anger and frustration and
loss of faith in the democracy it's not
an issue of democracy but it's
frustration about being left behind
being cut off not having access to
public services you want to have seeing
people leaving the region seeing your
children leaving the region which are
all signs of demographic change and this
demographic change this is my plea is
not a given it's not something we just
have to take as something like we can't
do anything about it on the contrary
there
is and this would take too much time
there are regions there cities that
showed successfully that you can stop
the decline you can make a turnaround
and you can improve on that topic again
and to bring this knowledge to the
different regions to map the European
Union to look for the best practices is
a fantastic task task it starts with the
topic of reconciliation of work and
family it goes deep into mobility
infrastructure it goes on with
perspectives and jobs you do have but it
also goes deep into the topic what are
we doing with an ageing workforce and
that can be there is a lot that can be
done so it's a vast topic as you see
with my short outlines and these are the
two main stakes she has to deal with
I wish me to wash man and then we go up
to the top
Jim press agency it difficulty with the
confirmation in in the European
Parliament and possibly even delay of
your start and on the first I know that
it is a very important process of the
hearings in the European Parliament and
each Commissioner each vice president
will have to convince without any
question so it's out of respect before
the Parliament that I am not the one
who's talking about the timelines the
Parliament will decide when to start the
hearings and the Parliament will decide
when they've heard enough and the
hearing stuff
thank you very much America with the
Wall Street Journal have two questions I
made the first ones about trade and US
relations just as you take office the
u.s. is about to get it will be about to
get awarded in the WTO Airbus case and
they've been quite intent on leveling
tariffs and we also have the car tariffs
that will come shortly after you're in
office
what's your game plan for trying to
convince President Trump and his
administration not to go down the tariff
rate do you have any meetings planned
and do you see positive agenda going
forward and secondly some of the ideas
that you put forth in your political
guidelines with regards to the European
Green Deal
such as the carbon tax and higher
ambitions for emissions cuts by 2030
have already been discussed repeatedly
at the EU level brought up by France
twice and partially by Spain
with regard to carbon border tax and the
55 percent reduction was shut down by
the Member States at the council who
agreed on a 40 percent reduction just
two years ago what do you think is
different this time and why would you
governments go along with your more
ambitious targets thank you this is I
start with your last question first this
is a topic that is gaining an enormous
amount of Drive and rightly so and the
council agreed on the goal of climate
neutrality so if we want to reach
climate neutrality in 2015 we have to
have reliable achievable steps before
this date that have to be taken you need
a plan we need a clear structure we need
to know and this is what we're talking
about with the European Green Deal
exactly how we want to move forward what
is doable where we have to be more
ambitious why we have to push forward
but I'm convinced if I may say so that
sooner or later every region on this
globe will have to join in the goal to
have a climate friendly behavior climate
friendly economy climate friendly
production lines so sooner or later the
whole globe will join in and then it is
of utmost importance
who has been the front runner who has
developed the technologies who has been
able to show what to do with Riaan
financing who has been able to show that
transition from co2 emission to a
different way of producing is doable
that it suggests transition so all these
factors are difficult we will have a lot
of problems on our way forward but it's
the right way to go and I'm determined
to have the European Union as being a
role Madeline model and a front-runner
will we'll learn on our way going ahead
we will certainly have periods that will
be more difficult than easy but the
direction is absolutely the right one
what the United States and the cherish
and WTO is concerned in general I think
we should always keep in mind that if we
start a tit for tat behavior whatever is
are concerned others will have the
benefit of it neither the United States
nor the European Union and therefore it
is always worth smart to sit down to
talk about the topics to think what is
in our common interest in our both
common in
just and then to move forward certainly
I will travel the moment I'm an office
but plants have not been detailed out
now you might get some water a good idea
already in my canoe and just qualifies
you for the next question I'm sorry
exactly portfolio it's protecting our
European Way of life but you said you
mentioned as well as migration so
protection by from what and do you
connect the protection of say European
Way of life with migration you see that
guideline that headline in my political
guidelines and there's a whole chapter
below it so every title is from the
political guidelines and our European
Way of life is holding up our values and
the beauty of the dignity of every
single human being is one of the most
precious balance the rule of law in
other words everybody has the same
rights is one of our founding principles
so and to find the balance within this
difficult topic never to forget our
founding values and rules is the
overarching topic on a very precise work
Margarita's kinas and the Commission's
of the cluster will have to do I
elaborated a lot on it already I talked
a lot about a sustainable concept
already but of course it's there is way
more into it no geographical balance
means that we've got to just yep you yes
Nicola Neil's new observer
actually I'm over here I was gonna ask
that question but it's been asked on
migration again so I'm gonna follow up
on something a little bit else on that
portfolio it does the Commission intend
to withdraw the reforms on the Dublin
regulation are you gonna stick to it
given all the problems that you've had
trying to reform it or are you going to
just pull it completely and start over
again thank you we will have to reform
Dublin without any question so and this
is a matter of solidarity it cannot be
by definition depending on your
geographical position this cannot be the
the source of having to carry the most
responsibility for example in the topic
of arriving migrants so Dublin will
certainly have to be reformed this is
something we're gonna talk intensively
about and this will be one of the top
topics on the agenda thank you very much
I'm over here I work for the Spanish
radio thank you very much for spending
all this time with us and answering all
these questions I have a question on
external policy because the name you've
chosen it's a bit awkward I mean I know
it's very difficult to hand out
portfolio but you could have had
something big you know with defense and
trade and everything foreign policy why
didn't you opt for this kind of profile
I'm just wondering is it that double
heart that you find a bit worrying you
don't want to give someone a double
portfolio and someone else first of all
the the portfolio of the high
representative
president is enormous I've been working
closely together with federica mogherini
and it was impressive to see how huge
her portfolio was and how brilliantly
she managed and Josep Burrell will do
the same so he has the same portfolio of
course there are a lot of topics that
have implications on the external action
but for example trade would you really
say trade is only something for the
external action it has a huge impact on
the internal market of the European
Union because you just mentioned trade
we will have a commissioners group for
the external action that will be working
together so that there is consistency
and coherence and our policy I think to
have these geopolitical view on our
tasks to have this external dimension as
a dominant one is for me one of the most
important topics in this commission as
I've said before I think the world needs
more Europe the world is calling for
more Europe therefore we have to stand
up this will not be easy but it's worth
to tackle it and to define very
precisely what is the European position
and then fight for it and work for it
and this will be a task for the whole
Commission knowing very well that Josef
Warrell will play an a crucial role in
that whole topic take another question
from that side please
let you at the corner
see Bulgaria intelligent btv Madam
President I have a question about this
whole procedure have you set certain
objectives regarding the future role of
past commissioners would you like to
promote them to posts with greater
responsibility and if so could you say
something about the Bulgarian
Commissioner Mario Gabriel from digital
issues to innovation and youth an
outstanding job in the digital portfolio
she had or has in this commission and
therefore I think she's the perfect
person to move on to the huge portfolio
of research and innovation it is crucial
for the European Union that we are from
trauma sphere and we make the right
decisions and research and innovation is
the basis for a successful economic
sector and she has the vast portfolio of
Education youth culture and sports in
other words she has with her the whole
Erasmus program this is what matters for
young people this is the most successful
European program we do have and rightly
so I'm a big fan of the Erasmus
programme so that is an enormous
responsibility but as I know Maria
Gabrielle as somebody who is determined
and who's capable she'll manage please
No you release turkey service start
eject and I have a follow-up on my curve
my colleague from New York Times Madame
elect president are you willing to open
negotiations on a new financial package
to Turkey because president aired on
clearly stated that he's going to open
the borders if if this is not the case
and on your selection mr. trottie Anya
for the enlargement for sure he must
have a pro enlargement views for Serbia
and Western Balkans but is he going to
be equally open minded when it comes to
other countries and if it's okay on the
same portfolio my colleague from
Hungarian service also has a question if
that's okay
turkey is concerned what I was talking
about to be very clear is that there are
different views on the question whether
the six billions what part of the six
billion has been paid and invested in
the refugee camps in the schooling of
the children down there or not
the numbers presented by Turkey way
smaller than those presented by the
Commission and I think it's a matter to
sit down and to prove accountability
should be easy that we have the same
numbers I'm talking about the existing
agreement so period and the rest we'll
see thank you David political icon join
we see the results of your efforts to
achieve near-perfect gender equity in
this new Commission obviously that's an
important symbolic statement can you but
can you tell us is there any substantive
difference that you expect in this
commission from its predecessors as a
result of having that balance and also
when the European Council put your name
forward it was clear they envisioned to
executive vice presidents as a way of
balancing among the political
affiliations with your liberal and
Social Democrat partners now the
addition of a third executive vice
president from your own EPP family does
that upset that balance in do you expect
any static in the European Parliament as
a result of that here - I start with the
second question if we look at the result
from a proposal from the European
Council we had EPP my person me myself
we had Marguerite West here we knew as
vice president and France timmermans snd
as vice president and Josette Burrell as
HR VP s and e2 and shall mission as
renew
for the council president of the council
so I'm talking about five decisions that
have been taken without any
representation of the Central and
Eastern European countries point number
one it was very important for me to find
a balance that as I showed on the map
shows that with vice presidents all the
different regions in the European Union
are represented now let's look at the
political parties we have three
presidents this is the president of the
Parliament snd the President of the
Council renew and me as president-elect
for the Commission EPP so the three
political parties that supported me are
represented if we look at the vice
presidents we have eight two of them for
Xenu renew three four s and D and three
four EPP this is absolutely the right
balance because if you look at the
member states we have six member states
renew we have 90 PP and 10's nd if you
look at the results from the election
the Parliament it is approximately 2/3
107 renew and if you are generous with
SMD it's 3/3 EPP and snd SMD has 150 and
EPP 180 so this is exactly mirrored in
the vice presidents and if you look at
the three executive vice president's
they represent the three parties so on
the presidential layer balance executive
vice president's balance vice presidents
in themselves balance political parties
plus geographical balance plus
gender balance in the college itself
as a president I'm free to decide that's
what I did ready to take it two more
questions
Madam President Elect are you ready to
take a few more questions so we will
just be gone the last last lap yeah too
close but we go to the right side one
for myself from Sky News I want to talk
to you about about brexit six weeks ago
you said there will be massively
negative consequences of a No Deal
brexit I wonder do you still think that
is true and also how long do you think
it will take to negotiate a free trade
agreement with the United Kingdom once
the country has left the EU
it is not in the common interest
neither of the united kingdom nor the
european union and will be way more
difficult than an orderly breaks it I
always have this opinion that I still
have it today it's in our common
interest we are not isolated on this
globe but we are in interaction with
others other players on this globe and
it's in our common interest to have a
orderly brexit so as long as the topic
brexit is not solved in the different
options that are there i cannot
speculate about timelines for free trade
agreement so please excuse on that but
this is impossible I have to go slowly
but surely to the last three questions
please yeah I think we take the last
question is it okay yes because it's
fine fine
it's James crisp from The Daily
Telegraph two questions please
what happens to Michele Barney in now
and are you ready for No Deal brexit if
one happens on the first of November
your your first day in office
preparations are done we updated
whatever was necessary what also the
option for a withdrawal agreement is
concerned it's absolutely updated so
anytime ready to be signed and Michel
Barnier did an outstanding job and we
will need his expertise so I will
discuss with him a prolongation but of
course it is also very much depending on
what kind of certainty we will have on
the first of November thank you so much
thank you so much we will back to the
back yeah thanks a lot